if you and Kobe could just share the
ball more
and get along and stop talking to the
press and just concentrate when quince
Carl gets back it's gonna be okay you'll
see oh hi just
this this steroid thing you know a lot
of people want to know what are the
stars thinking when they sit here this
is such a very difficult situation for
everybody a lot of pressure now I've
done the show this is my eighth time
doing it and I'm telling you I can look
into your face and I can tell you what
you're thinking right alright so if you
look at the screen I'll tell you what's
going through all of these stars heads
this is a nice place I don't think I've
ever been thrown out of here I can't
believe what he came all this way just
to sit out there in my car if people
only knew what Bill Murray whispered in
my ear at the end of the movie was moved
to the left you're in my light no no
your left
god this sunburst nipple brooch is
killing me mrs. Billy Crystal pushy
galore I just got it
that's Bogard
mrs. Billy Crystal sir mrs. Billy
Crystal yeah
don't hate me because I'm beautiful just
hate me because I'm rich you don't wanna
talk about rich girlfriends
yeah Oh Oh everybody send back I'm gonna
present my little Oscar right now who to
the owner of a Ford Coppola your lights
are on don't be afraid who the great
thing about Botox is if you lose tonight
you can't frown who William Morris has
hired the station agent jack valenti
your DVDs already somewhere Sacheen
Littlefeather is going hit me double
down hit me hit me
Double Down we're the children of Strom
Thurmond please pick up a white or black
courtesy phone
and that's what all of you are thinking
that's what's going through your minds I
know it as you sit there right now
thanks for being a good sport hi
we'll talk after I know our next
presenters are Will Smith and Jada
Pinkett Smith they're attractive
intelligent warm honest in love with
each other and great parents what a
disgrace to the entire Hollywood
communities to our ladies and gentlemen
please welcome Will Smith and Jada
Pinkett Smith
if film directors had to wait for the
perfect conditions at sea or the massing
of armies of extras or the appearance of
ghost ships films would never ever be
finished instead they turned to the
special-effects magicians who conjure up
these perfect visions for them the
nominees
I'd like this feels great sweetie I'm
sorry just I'm doing with my wife I'm
just happy the nominees tonight for
achievement and visual effects are for
the Lord of the Rings The Return of the
King
Jim Rygel Jolla Terry Randall William
cook and Alex funky for Master and
Commander the far side of the world Dan
suiting Stefan Fangmeier Nathan McGinnis
and Robert Stromberg for Pirates of the
Caribbean the curse of the Black Pearl
John Knoll Hal Hickel Charles Gibson and
Terry fuzzy and the Oscar goes to babe
i'ma let you read the reading cuz there
cuz some of the names are hard
Jim Rygel Jolla Terry Randall William
cook and Alex funky for Lord of the
Rings The Return of the King
this is the third Academy Award for Jim
Riggle
Randall William cook and Alex funky and
the second one for Joel eteri they all
took home the Oscar last year in this
category for the Lord of the Rings the
two towers
trilogy I thanks you thank yous to the
Academy uh amazingly brilliant Peter
Jackson wherever you are out there Fran
Walsh Barry Osborne Lauren Richey my VFX
crew Dean right Libby hazel Aaron Co and
all the people in Wetty and Theresa
Saren Jackson my family so thanks to you
for being so generous to us for the last
three years running thanks Pete and
thanks to my wonderful animation team
yeah thanks everyone for this the
amazing reception we've gotten to the
work Thank You Eileen Moran for keeping
it all together a Peter and Fran for
being such an inspiration
everyone at wet a digital for that burst
of creative energy thank you thank you
Peter Fran Barry
Richard my darling wife Emmy and my
brilliant Kiwi effects team thank you